we all have share the same challenges
worldwide
we all want um
when we bring together the innovation
and the support system globally i think
we can go stronger as a society
if it's health issues if it's climate if
it's food we all struggle with the same
challenges
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet adi
barrel managing director of the eit hub
israel
adi is an internationally renowned
expert in innovation and business
development specializing in strategy
partnership building and global
networking today she is managing
director of the european institute of
innovation and technology eit israel hub
an organization that aims to create
synergies between the european
innovation community and the israeli
ecosystem founding strong collaborations
and international partnerships the eit
hub that was established in 2019 is
focusing on strategic domains such as
health climate energy digital
manufacturing and mobility
adi bagel welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for being here today
thank you for having me
european union israeli ecosystem
innovation we're going to have a lot of
fun in these 20 minutes adi you're the
managing director of the eit hub in
israel but prior you've dealt with quite
a few um business development
roles that are in conjunction with
international relations whether it's
with the massa israel journey or in the
tel aviv global so so definitely i'm
excited to understand you know where
this passion for you know international
relations with innovation is coming from
and then understand a little bit better
you know what is the eit hub and how is
it playing a role in the israeli
ecosystem so first of all thank you very
much for being here
thank you again uh so let's start with
the global career that i'm having
so um
as i always say for me um having a
a career that is not global is not
tapping into the different uh worlds and
different places around the world is
like having a laptop with no wi-fi it
just doesn't have a soul for me the
world is global and anything that we do
here
from israel in israel has to be also
have a global impact so this is why
from the moment i graduate from the
university i i was looking for a global
career and this is this what led me into
this this world
it's kind of on the bridge between
innovation
government and
international relations
and so
you know going even back be before that
you know what prompted your curiosity
towards the conjunction of three things
is it a personality thing is it an
experience that you had
that's a good question
actually i think
my first job was actually i was working
for the haifa municipality i was a law
student back then
and
my job was actually to build a community
of international students in the haifa
municipality
just
the students from the technion and haifa
university and all the old fans and then
i just i realized there is a bigger
community there is a jewish community um
around the world and then it was um it
made me feel very curious about what is
happening outside the world how israel
is conceived outside
of our little country
and
that led me actually to explore
different places different location and
different jobs
amazing okay so you know going to
european union and israel because i
think that's something that will take us
time to to uncover here
first
tell me a little bit about the european
union as a body
that's interested in innovation and
innovation hubs what what what is the
sort of the rationale over there
so europe the european union for many
years is investing a lot of uh source
resources and a lot of time into
developing of innovation the development
of innovation the only issue is that
many of the good ideas from the from
europe are not getting commercialized in
the right way
um
from there uh the european union decided
to establish the eit the elt basically
is the european institute of innovation
and technology and the whole idea around
that is to support to create a support
system
to technologies to ideas and to start up
to grow and that's the main agenda of
the eit basically it's based on the
knowledge triangle um it's a combination
between industry academia and research
government and all of this ecosystem is
supporting the growth of startups in
different domains
adding to that the european union is
very advanced on
impact what we call impact technology
that means that the eat is focusing on
domains that are conceived as impact
technologies such as health climate
energy food
urban mobility manufacturing raw
materials and those domain so the eats
is supporting the domain that are
strategic to humanity
and create a support system for them
that's a general overview about the e18
to 2018 the ait decided to establish
what we call outreach location
hubs
outside of the european union with the
idea of we have to collaborate to make
it work startup cannot grow
um locally startups have to to grow
globally they have to communicate if we
want to create a real support system we
have to do it globally so the eat and
europe they chose a few locations that
they feel they are strategic
to startup development one location was
silicon valley we have a hub a sister
hub in silicon valley the other other
location is israel and we are going to
open two more locations in the next two
years
so in israel what we have here is a hub
that is focused on building bridges
building building commercial
collaboration between the european
ecosystem in those specific domains and
the israeli ecosystem which has as you
know a lot to offer there
phenomenal and so if you're looking now
you know in your day-to-day are you
working more closely with the managers
of the other hubs are you working more
with the with the ecosystem that we have
here how does your day-to-day look like
so the way we think and the way we
create our programs and our value is
that basically we have stakeholders our
stakeholders are players in the european
ecosystem they are the main clients we
work for the european ecosystem so we
recognize the stakeholders once you
recognize the stakeholder it can be an
european corporate it can be a european
incubator vc you name it
then you recognize what is their main
need what is their pain
from that you you think and you what is
the unique value proposition of israel
in that in the for that need
and and if israel can benefit uh we we
all focus in creating a mutual benefit
from both israel and europe and once we
have the answers for all those we create
a program a program can be a scouting
program for
european corporates that are looking for
innovation it can be a support program
for scale-up companies from israel or
from europe that are looking um for
global scale matchmaking with clients
with vcs it can be we have one program
for european diplomats that are based in
israel we actually train them
how to better work with israeli
ecosystem
the idea is to get them get them working
very very quick
and very very efficient when they are in
israel we don't want them to spend time
on learning so we create this boot camp
for them it's kind of like a basic
training when we give them all the tools
and all the network they need to make
their job better that serve both
ecosystem europe and israel
so me i think it would help
and would be very interesting to hear
some more tangible ways in which the eat
is an active part of both the israeli
ecosystem but then as an outreach to the
european union what are some other ways
in which eit has been active in this
ecosystem
um so
yeah so what we realize is one european
corporates
are looking for good technology and good
practices for how to innovate
many of them we don't even know about we
don't even know their names but
they are very attractive for israeli
companies in israeli startups on the
other hand we know that israeli startups
always aim and look for
global markets right the eu can be a
very attractive market for them so one
program we offer is disrupt me uh in
that program the european corporate is
the main client and we support the
corporates in
one scout for the best technology
to implement technology and get to pocs
and three build their innovation open
innovation strategy based on
israel's best practices and know how you
so you are essentially a liaison for a
lot of these european
conglomerates or
incumbents and saying okay these are you
know you have this this is your problem
set and we are you know sort of the
ambassadors of the israeli community and
we can then help you scout for the right
technologies and the right teams to
potentially work with from israel right
did they get that right
exactly adding to that is that israel
has developed best practices and models
in open innovation in the past 60 years
and those models and know-how
are also something that we support
european corporates with
to actually
uh teach them how to to fish
and not just give them the startups
one example
what surprised you about your work with
the european union or or you know comp
large companies and startups that you
probably didn't realize you know three
years ago when you started working with
eit
so i've learned a lot uh before coming
to eit i was uh working uh quite often
with the american market with the u.s
market
and switching to europe uh made me
realize one
is that european culture and europe are
very they are very humble
it's very they are very um
very the young generation is very global
and
it's very fun to work with them very
good teams
so that was a big surprise for me as an
israeli second i realized that israeli
startups many times won't aim to europe
as a first market
and they do need a push for that they do
need someone to connect them to the
right
market the right way so this is
something that we took upon ourselves to
do to promote and support startups going
to europe and scaling in europe
and the third thing is that as i realize
this europe is very advanced in impact
technology you know climate regulation
energy
and sometimes it can be the perfect
better site for startup in startups in
those fields
what what do entrepreneurs and leaders
in today's ecosystem need to understand
some perhaps some things that they can
also work on today
as they're gearing to work with the
european market whether it's through eit
or or by themselves but what are some
things that they should be
practicing or doing right now that will
make it an easier transition for them
i will just need you to repeat that
question transition to europe or to
today's world
so if you're looking at founders today
or leaders today in the israeli market
as they're positioning to work with
european market later on whether it's
through eit or by themselves
you know what what are some things that
they can already start working on today
that you see
are drawbacks of the israeli ecosystem
because we're unaware of it
yes okay so first of all is the domain
focus and the technologies in israel we
see today a trend and it's growing um
of of energy climate
um and technologies that uh today the
world is interested in
so today we see we do see a shift on the
early stage startup and on the the
supportive ecosystems around uh climate
and energy technologies
hopefully that will grow uh get we see
many players
vcs and other players are getting into
this uh ecosystem so i hope this trend
will grow and that will give a very good
ground to work between europe and israel
in addition to that i mean i think
israelis need more connectors more
organic connections in europe
we see that happening very successfully
in the usa
very easy plug-in if i am an israeli
entrepreneur i pick up the phone and
write an email very easy for me to get
to new york to boston to san francisco
in in europe is more challenging and
what we are trying to build today is
a community of connectors between israel
and europe and i think that will be will
take us to the next step
are there cultural shifts that we need
to be cognizant of or aware of as we're
you know working with european
counterparts is that is that something
that we need to be thinking about
i get this question often i think that
today
cultural differences or gaps are getting
embarrassed and embraced by the other
side
so i think people have a lot of a lot
more
um
openness
and openness
yeah patience yeah
yeah to
uh for differences and they actually
learn from that
so i will give you an example
when we bring delegations of of european
here we used to be very afraid okay what
will they say and how will they behave
but today what we do is first of all we
have a wall no suits allowed
i love business people no suits allowed
we have like a big x on that they cannot
wear any suit where they are while they
are how are they responding to that
some are are better and some just ignore
the fool
but
we do
we do um support them to get out of
their comfort zone
second
we teach them three words we teach them
and these three words are what we expect
from them when they come to israel
so we do try to navigate through these
cultural gaps and actually create a
learning experience and a benefit out of
it and not a gap
beautiful well so what are you more
excited about innovation or
international relations which of the two
i think innovation is a tool
for international relations
so i think everything can be um
can be communicated through business
through innovation and through mutual
challenges we all have share the same
challenges worldwide
we all want um
when we bring together the innovation
and the support system globally i think
we can go stronger as a society
if it's health issues if it's climate if
it's food we all struggle with the same
challenges
right
do you see
you know if you're looking a few a few
years down the line
in you know specifically the european
union or european countries the european
market with israel
i'm sure we're heading at an you know at
a
positive rate but you know what what is
sort of the expectation from your end
are you you know is it are we going to
are we going to see you know
exponentially more work with with europe
is it just going to continue rising
slowly what what do you observe here
yes so historically israel and europe
has 25 years of successful innovation
collaboration
i don't know if you've heard about
orient 2020
that
ended in last december
a year ago uh and
and lately uh israel signed an
association agreement with europe
uh and israeli association country to
horizon europe which is the new
framework program for innovation
development and support
so having said that there is an
expectation that israel will be an
active participant
and also will collaborate with other
players across europe
to get to more projects to more funding
and to create innovation together and is
politics related at all to this or is
this innovation to innovation
how much of politics and lobbying is in
in what you're saying here
yeah so i can speak uh for myself uh we
try in the eat hub israel to avoid
politics as much as possible to make us
as much as uh clean
and with no
agenda
our main agenda is support collaboration
support business commercially
commercialization
business collaboration
and and innovation and we try to avoid
politics we know it can
create different
different agendas and
yeah fantastic if you could add i think
that
you're um
we're talking about here is just opening
you know so many more questions for me
that i want to investigate and i think
that in general if you ask most israeli
entrepreneurs i think that the default
question at least until now that i've
heard was the u.s market but i think
they were forgetting that the european
market is just a little bit bigger than
that of the us
and and and definitely but much better
time zone as well and so i'm excited to
i'm saying it in myself also that i need
to educate myself and i think that what
you're doing with the iet hub is just
phenomenal both from an international
relations perspective but also from an
innovation perspective
you know looking at what we have here
being an ambassador for us and but also
being a liaison for a lot of these big
european markets and companies and br
and making literally making that that
geographical bridge i think is just
awesome and thank you very very much for
spending these 20 minutes with me i
really appreciate your time and your
energy and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much and if you need
anything about europe
just join us come to an event and feel
free to are you so you're doing you're
are they you're doing regular events
both for the general public to get
educated but also for startups and these
sorts of things
we have the best event in the ecosystem
that i can i can assure you that and i'm
gonna have to check it for myself
thank you very much take care
[Music]